what's going on guys this is rob and per
your request we are remastering
spider-verse at least 70 of you guys
said you wanted me to remaster
spider-verse more like 75 because
spider-man no way home is a giant
multiversal story so i guess it makes
sense and so in order to make things
easier for you guys i'm gonna put the
reading order down in the description so
you guys can basically keep up as you
guys buy the comics and and read them
and so on and so forth uh but this picks
up with superior spider-man now for
those of you guys who don't know what
that is superior spider-man was the
story arc where dr octopus took over the
body of peter parker and so he basically
became the new spider-man it was an
amazing story the entirety of the
spider-verse event actually happens
between two issues with superior
spider-man so you don't really see the
event play out per se in the superior
spider-man comic as it was initially
written instead what you get are
superior spider-man tie-in stories to
the events of spider-verse and so the
way this had happened is that there was
basically this giant explosion that took
place uh that was a result of a temporal
meltdown at horizon labs now those are
guys you may be familiar with it if you
guys saw the morbius trailer you saw
horizon one of the buildings in the
background it was literally the only
building with red lighting on it right
red wording so of course we seem to know
that mobius takes place in the marvel
cinematic universe or at least that
seems to be the case horizon labs is
really a think tank when it comes to the
marvel comics universe right just where
a bunch of smart people hang out and
just think of cool stuff and so with
that explosion taking place superior
spider-man was thrown into the time
stream now this happening was actually
pretty cool because if you look at the
scene where he's thrown into the time
stream in the very top left hand corner
that's the earth x captain america
that's actually the universe that the
eternal's film is based off of next to
him is what looks like the incredible
hulk because it is he's actually called
maestro and it's basically a future
version of the incredible hulk where the
world had succumbed to like nuclear war
and he basically led this city called
dystopia over on geek culture explained
i still stand by the fact and i'm making
the argument over there that what bruce
banner saw in avengers age of ultron was
actually himself becoming the maestro
but you just see these kind of alternate
realities right old man logan different
things along those lines but he's just
kind of thrown into the time stream
until ultimately he arrives in the 2099
universe now the 2099 universe of marvel
comics is actually a really really cool
universe it was created by peter david
and it's been around since the 90s in
fact it was one of the more popular
lines of comics marvel had in the 90s
like most of those alternate realities
like the ultimate universe stuff like
that it started with spider-man and then
over time just became less interesting
you got stuff like the 2099 incredible
hulk and like 2099 punisher and doctor
doom and different things along those
lines but it's basically
the the future right now instead of
having like new york what you have is
nueva york just kind of like this future
super technologically advanced place but
by and large the whole area is ran by
alcamax and this is important because
once superior spider-man gets into this
place because he's somewhat familiar
with 2099 then of course he's able to
make his way through there to a degree
and he's basically set upon by what's
referred to as the public eye now the
public eye in the 2099 universe they're
basically private police that are
actually hired and work for alcamax the
company that seemingly runs everything
or at least basically all of new york
but when this happens of course he's
able to get past these guys quite
readily and then he's met by gabriel
o'hara now gabriel o'hara is the brother
of miguel o'hara also known as spiderman
2099. at the moment he's not here he's
missing he's actually out doing his own
thing and we'll follow up with him
relatively soon but the idea of dr
octopus a really superior spider-man
being in this place of course he's
greeted by gabriel and he's like i don't
need you anymore right like all i want
to do is find my way back home back to
my native universe and we're going to
call it a day now here's the funny thing
about this when it comes to dr octopus
historically in the movies his
intelligence has been downplayed despite
how smart you've seen him come off in
the movies he's not nearly as
intelligent in the movies as he is in
the comics in the comics he's light
years ahead of everybody he's like tony
stark right he's a futurist he's always
thinking to the future always looking to
the horizon and so he's basically given
this kind of sentient ai computer system
which is partially self-aware but still
has to follow the programming that's
assigned to it and asks it the best way
to achieve interdimensional travel or
time travel now as you would expect time
travel is highly regulated in any one
particular universe and a lot of this
falls in line with the nature of
organizations like the time variance
authority itself as well as the
organizational structures of that
particular universe and what i mean by
that is the tva as most of you guys
probably know from the loki series
albeit that series was a little bit
different from the comics that it is by
and large governed by the time keepers
and the goal of the timekeepers is to
basically ensure their existence right
that they come into existence at the end
of time and they want to make sure that
like nothing happens across the
multiverse that prevents them from
existing and so they closely monitor
individuals who travel back and forth
through time making sure they don't
disrupt the time stream too much so
there's that kind of regulation that
goes into it at the same time if you're
a massive company like alcomax and you
have all this power you don't want
anybody going back in time and
preventing your company from existing
and so that's the kind of regulation you
end up seeing people who aren't meddling
with time and like disrupting existing
status quos or possibly even sending the
universe on a collision course to a far
worse future than the one that currently
exists so there's all kinds of things
you can screw up with time and that's
why it's monitored so closely
fortunately for us superior spider-man
doesn't care
it doesn't matter to him and in fact he
actually ends up breaking into all these
different facilities and stealing all
these different things he needs in order
to attain the ability to travel through
time or to move from one dimension or
one universe to the next now with doctor
octopus he can get away with that right
it's like giving tony stark the ability
to achieve time travel just part and
parcel of his intelligence is knowing
there's some things you just can't do
right you can't disrupt time too much
you've got to be very very careful
another part of this is that as he's
been working with this ai and this is a
particularly important point going
forward he actually tells it to start
modifying its physical appearance so it
looks like anna maria marconi now the
reason why that matters is anna maria
marconi was a diminutive woman who was
also incredibly intelligent and actually
challenged otto octavius in a lot of
different ways she believed he was peter
parker she didn't really know the truth
she found out later on but she was one
of the few people out there that kept
pushing him to be better and so because
of the fact that she was not content
with mediocrity she would call him out
when he was wrong she would say like
you're better than what you currently
are right now it wasn't just i like you
as you are and that's fine right she
wanted to see him become better to live
up to his full potential that he
actually developed a huge amount of
respect for and then started falling in
love with her and so he basically misses
her and that all ties into the nature of
superior spider-man right doctor octopus
basically reforming becoming a hero
instead of a villain forming parker
industries which actually became like
this worldwide multi-billion dollar
philanthropy based organization he
created all these little pieces of
technology that made peter parker's life
better as spider-man it was really
really cool in terms of how all that
stuff worked but once the actual system
is set up and he's ready to travel one
of the things he had done is created a
snapback protocol so that if he ends up
jumping into an alternate universe and
like it's in the middle of a meteor
crashing into it and everyone's dying he
can snap back
because wouldn't it suck if he traveled
to a new universe and a meteor was about
to crash into it he had like 10 seconds
to live and that was that right like it
would it would really blow balls and so
once he ends up passing through because
of the nature of traveling through the
multiverse is not as simple as simply
just jumping back to a period in time
trying to travel through space and time
the fact of the multiverse actually
moves the way the earth orbits around
the sun that is a very very precise
system and so he ultimately ends up
missing where it is that he's supposed
to be instead he shows up in an
alternate reality where spider-man had
joined the fantastic four and this
version of spider-man's been killed not
only that he snaps back and ends up in
an alternate reality the house of m
universe most of you guys have heard of
that the universe with the scarlet witch
had basically rewrote reality to give
everybody everything they subconsciously
desired spider-man in that universe is
killed then he snaps back and ends up in
a civil war universe where basically the
civil war never ended and that version
of spider-man is killed that every
single universe he goes to the
spider-men in these different universes
have all been killed they've been
executed but the more crazy thing about
this is they've all been killed in the
exact same way the two same puncture
marks right so seemingly someone or
something is traveling around the
multiverse and killing all these
different versions of spider-man and so
what it does is it switches over towards
probably one of the cooler versions of
spider-man once superior spider-man
jumps back to 2099 and then jumps into
the time stream again you actually end
up in an alternate reality where you get
spider-man india which is cool and then
you find the guy who's basically killing
everybody now this thing here this guy
he's what's called an inheritor and
we'll learn more about the inheritors as
time goes on the important thing and
really what dan slock gives us here is
that this guy spider-man india seemingly
has all the same powers that you would
expect from a spider-man right like the
powers of peter parker so like the
proportional strength of a spider the
ability to climb on walls shoot webbing
different things like that a lot of that
stuff just kind of universal from one
universe to the next but this guy this
spider-man india is getting totally
wrecked by by this inheritor right i
mean literally he's just fleeing for his
life nothing's working absolutely
nothing is working here and so what you
end up getting is this this kind of cat
and mouse game this incredible maneuver
that's made by this inheritor where he
actually ends up forcing a building to
crumble which draws the attention of
spider-man because as you guys know
spider-man would never let innocent
people die and then in turn because he's
distracted it's basically game over
there's no way for this guy to win and
then enter superior spider-man who saves
this dude's life right just saves this
guy's life by an instant i mean this
dude was like moments away from being
killed and so once this guy is basically
defeated of course he's you know we
really have superhero spider-man telling
us this guy's being held at bay he
starts talking to spider-man india and
what he says is that as he's been
traveling through the multiverse
presumably trying to find his way home
his mission to get back to the main
marvel universe shifted because every
universe he came across spider-man were
being killed and dr octopus being as
intelligent as he is deduced someone or
something is hunting spider-man from
across the multiverse and so it's only a
matter of time before they come for him
and so what he actually has been doing
is assembling a team of different
spider-man from across the multiverse
all of whom intend to face off against
this guy this person that's basically
taking them all out and so once
spider-man india is brought back to the
marvel 2099 universe you end up seeing
like five other spider-man including
spider-man noir but one of them is also
assassin spider-man who's one of the
coolest versions of the character okay
so here's here's the origin of assassin
spider-man right we're gonna switch over
to this it's actually kind of a backup
feature in superior spider-man number
32. that what you end up finding out
here is that somewhere along the line
the green goblin had actually murdered
gwen stacy and unlike the main marvel
universe where the death of gwen stacy
taught peter parker that he couldn't be
reckless and this alternate reality the
death of gwen stacy taught spider-man to
take no prisoners and so every single
villain that he had that he came across
he killed he just executed him right
like craving the hunter he just killed
them as he should have been doing and of
course one of the things that also goes
on here is that because there are some
threats out there that spider-man's
going to have to contend with and his
skills aren't quite up to snuff he
actually ends up training with wolverine
now this may seem kind of like weird to
have him train with wolverine but it
actually makes perfect sense and the
reason why is because wolverine's
trained a lot of people in marvel comics
black widow learned how to fight from
wolverine when she was in the red room
you had all kinds of people who have
trained with this guy right and it's one
of these things in marvel comics it's a
hodgepodge somewhere along the line
seemingly everybody's trained with
everybody else the only real exception
to that insofar as the one person that
like everybody's trained with is
actually two people and they're really
more teachers than anything else the
first one is taskmaster right like tony
masters that guy i mean he's the guy you
want to train with he usually trains
villains but heroes have trained with
him as well but the other person and
probably the more significant trainer of
heroes in mobile comics is shang chi
he's trained really almost everyone in
some form or fashion even if there's
someone like wolverine that already had
a formidable set of skills all change he
did was hone them and make them better
so again it's one of these things where
tony masters and shane cheer kind of
like the one-two punch of people that
you train with but this guy this version
of spider-man training with wolverine
made him far more ruthless and far more
brutal because it's just the nature of
wolverine's training and so of course
when this inheritor showed up in that
universe and immediately started going
after that version of spider-man the
assassin spider-man that wolverine
stepped in the way and wolverine was
totally incinerated right of course all
that's really left is this adamantium
skeleton now this is one of those things
where marvel plays it fast and loose if
you read days of future past marvel's
like yeah man wolverine's entire
skeleton was incinerated and he died but
then you go when you read a story like
civil war where nitro blows up in front
of wolverine and reduces him down to his
skeleton and he regrows right so it's
one of those things where it just kind
of goes either way wolverine's ability
to heal from an injury is more of a plot
device than anything else especially
when it's an injury this extreme but
what it does is it allows assassin
spider-man to basically temporarily gain
the upper hand on this inheritor even if
only for a moment now during this
process he's actually met by alex now
we're not given a whole lot of
information about alex all we really
know is that she's basically the girl
that this version of spider-man ended up
with that liked the maine marvel
universe that following the death of
gwen stacy peter parker at least in this
reality ended up with mary jane watson
but then along the way he met alex he
broke up with mary jane watson and got
with alex instead most likely it seems
to be because the mentality alex had is
more in line with the mentality of
assassin's spiderman but at the end of
the day you actually get this really
really cool moment where assassins
spiderman's fighting the inheritor and
he realizes his staff basically relies
on energy and so his response is then
we'll just overload it right so he
actually leads him to this location
which is just a giant power battery more
or less and as the two of them are
fighting the staff is temporarily
overloaded but at the end of the day the
inheritor pulls it back out and the
fight's on again it's one of these
things where he's just kind of like i'm
entertained right like your death will
be quicker than most because you know
you kind of gave me a good fight right i
respect you so i'm not going to kill you
slowly and so ultimately this guy kind
of just seems to be unstoppable there's
no real way for anyone to overcome him
but then what actually ends up happening
is that while this fight's taking place
superior spider-man shows up he ends up
ripping a tree out of the ground and
throwing it at this dude and sending him
flying and so that's the explanation of
how it is that as these two meet up
superior spider-man had assassin's
spider-man in his ranks because he saved
yet another spider-man from being killed
by one of the inheritors now at this
point we switch over to what's called
the edge of spider-verse so the way the
spider-verse was told it was told in a
couple different forms the first is that
you followed superior spider-man then
you go into edge of spider-verse which
is basically these stories that give you
like either origins on different
versions of spider-man or stories
involving existing spider-man from
across the multiverse in terms of how it
all ties together and how they ended up
as part of the spider-verse event and so
in this instance we actually end up
picking up with spider-man noir who's
actually been around since 2009. so he
was he appeared about five years before
this story was written and one of the
things to know the way peter parker
gained his powers in this particular
story because the marvel noir series was
designed to be a lot more grounded than
what you saw in terms of just the
traditional marvel comics line so like
radioactive spiders biting people and
instead of them succumbing to radiation
poisoning they get powers but what you
actually saw here was basically a kind
of spider idol which really seemed to be
imbued with magical energy so i mean i
guess you know kind of grounded
[Laughter]
i don't know but regardless peter parker
in this universe was bitten by one of
those fighters and then he woke up with
the with spider-man powers as you would
expect what you also have here is
somebody called uh the magical mysterio
or like the amazing mysterio what's
really going on here and kind of an
important thing to understand these
aren't really significant moments we're
really covering this because of the way
that it ends but basically mysterio is a
guy the magnificent mysterio he's a guy
vying for power right wilson fist
kingpin is running new york he's the guy
that wants to take his places like the
new crime boss is really all it is and
that's one of the things that kind of
happens is you have this bit of a
discussion where like wilson fisk walks
in on mysterio talking about how he's
going to basically steal the powers of
spider-man and then in turn he's going
to be the one to run new york right so
when you're wilson fisk that stuff
doesn't really bother you because you
know that people are just going to come
gunning for you at some point along the
line and so one of the things that goes
on here is you actually have wilson fisk
trying to gain information on the
identity of spider-man and that's been
an ongoing theme in the spider-man noir
series for quite some time they actually
end up visiting felicia hardy now
felicia hardy was at one point in a
relationship with a villain called the
crime master but was in love with
spider-man noir and when the crime
master learned this he ended up slashing
her face and that's why she wears a
white mask because her face is scarred
all the hell and so because of that it's
basically like her saying like i don't
know the identity of spider-man i'm in
love with him but i don't know him
personally but while all this is
happening right all these little plot
threads and things like that are going
on peter parker in this universe is
experiencing this kind of dull headache
that just kind of seems to be sitting
back there there really doesn't seem to
be any indication in terms of the fact
there's like an immediate threat that's
kind of how his spider sense manifests
it's sort of a dull pain but it just
kind of kicks in whenever any like
massive event takes place so very very
similar to the spider sense of peter
parker from the main marvel universe but
what his sense is basically telling him
is there's a threat out there somewhere
and it's kind of a kind of a bit of an
annoyance here because if it's like if
there's a threat out there somewhere
like why doesn't this threat manifest
itself right i mean keep in mind peter
parker's fighter since doesn't tell him
where the threat is coming from it just
says there is a threat there kind of
like a sixth sense and he even refers to
it as like an esp to a degree but during
this whole thing because of the fact
that mysterio is trying to get his hands
on on the blood of spiderman noir for
the purpose of finding a way to
basically make himself someone that has
powers akin to spider-man that he
actually ends up challenging spider-man
noir publicly in the newspapers by
saying like there is going to be a girl
you're gonna have to rescue right can
you live up to the challenge that kind
of a thing now behind the scenes the
indication is he's actually going to
kill her like mysterio really will kill
this girl if spider-man noir doesn't
show up and because he's a quote-unquote
magician the audience will believe it's
a trick when it's actually real right
and spider-man noir will kind of have to
live with that so of course he ends up
showing up here and when that happens
he's overcome pretty quickly by a kind
of uh gaseous substance which basically
knocks him out temporarily and then of
course he's hoisted up and in response
to that the entire you know casket
basically that he's in is filled with
water keep in mind this is all real it's
designed to look like a trick to the
audience because they're like oh man
this is crazy mysterio couldn't kill
spider-man in front of everybody right
it's only he can march him out on stage
put a gun to the back of his head and
shoot him by because they would all be
like my god you killed a man but like if
you make it look like a trick then it's
like wow that was so impressive we
watched a man die but we're too foolish
to know what actually happened right
that kind of a thing now at this point
you get this kind of plot device where
basically spider-man noir shoots webbing
on his face which like traps a bit of
oxygen and then he's like the oxygen
saved me from drowning right and it's
that kind of a thing now honestly it
would kill him because he's he's
exhaling co2 right so basically he's
breathing in a poisonous substance the
oxygen would run out but it's comic book
logic roll with it
don't ask too many questions guys if you
try to take comic books too seriously
you're going to make yourself go crazy
and so of course he ends up basically
making his escape he fights mysterio you
know kind of beats him up a little bit
and the day's more or less saved and he
frees felicia hardy and all that kind of
stuff and that's it and then the
inheritor pops up and that's kind of how
this happens right these guys teleport
into universes right teleport into these
spaces and so when this guy arrives
superior spider-man shows up it's one of
these things where literally superior
spider-man teleports in grabs spider-man
war and teleports out and that's it
because by this point in time as this
kind of conversation begins to progress
and we start to get into the next part
of our little story here that what you
have is basically the realization by
superior spider-man they can't beat this
guy as a small number hence the reason
why the entire team was formed and so
what you get is a is a different reality
where you basically have cyborg
spider-man he's pretty cool where he
looks pretty amazing this inheritor
shows up and then you actually end up
finding out that at some point along the
line superior spider-man visited cyborg
spider-man and informed him of what was
going on that seemingly the inheritor
would come after him somewhere along the
line and that ultimately when that
happens he actually ends up calling in
all these different spider-man rights
like spider-man india spider-man noir
the superior spider-man spider-girl
rights like ashley barton from the old
man logan universe she was amazing oh my
god i loved her character so much and
old man logan did you guys remember that
she was all like helpless and she needed
to be saved and then like once she was
saved she was like i'm ruling everything
now she like turned out to be a villain
it was awesome by the way if you guys
want to see like the origins or
explanations on any of the characters
that we cover here that you're not like
familiar with let me know and like i'll
make you know what kind of like pause
the series for a second and make videos
about some of these characters because i
feel like some of you guys are going to
want to know like the origins of these
guys and things along those lines but
ultimately they all end up teaming up
against against this inheritor and they
actually draw this really cool
conclusion superior spider-man realized
that while this guy is going around
killing spider-man then what he's doing
is absorbing their energy and so finding
a way to reverse engineer that process
he could actually use that energy
against him right they could basically
siphon that energy off of him and
basically make him weak the nature of
ashley barton right like the daughter of
hawkeye the nature of her is she's kinda
like okay we gotta kill this guy right
like we gotta take this guy out and it's
one of the things where the other
spiderman are like really like you wanna
kill like i mean are you sure about that
and then like assassins spiderman's like
yeah man he's been killing us right like
we just gotta eliminate this guy be done
with it call it a day why would we let
this guy live he's gonna find some way
to escape what do you think's gonna
happen he's gonna be in prison and then
realize his heart was three sizes too
small and he's gonna become a good guy
and help us is that really what you
think is gonna happen no he's a villain
kill him
and so there's this kind of big debate
that goes on there but superior
spider-man steps in and says before we
kill this guy at all we need information
right and so we asked him like what's
your mission and the response to the
inheritor is like there is no mission
right this is what my kind does we kill
spiders it's our way as for others like
me pray you never meet the rest of my
family and that's when it takes superior
spiderman by surprise like wait a minute
wait a minute there's more than one of
you and his response is like oh yeah
there's there's more than one of us and
so the question superior spider-man asks
here is will my weapon function as well
against these others i warn you i will
know if you lie and the response to this
guy is i mean sure like it'll function
as well against the others as it does
against me which is completely and
totally ineffective and then just like
breaks out right and it's just like i
was just wanting to hear what you guys
were saying i just wanted to hear what
your plan was understand what you guys
were doing and this massive fight breaks
out now all these spider-man are facing
one inheritor they're doing what they
can but at the end of the day even for
just one inheritor they're all being
painfully overpowered right i mean like
they're attacking as best they can but
they can't kill this guy right like all
they can do is kind of throw them around
pummel him a little bit they set him on
fire and it doesn't work and then it's
just like okay this could not possibly
get any worse and they're suddenly met
by the arrival of two other inheritors
now of course you learned this guy we've
been following the whole time his name
is karn but basically he's kind of seen
as like a shameful member of the family
not as powerful just kind of kind of
shame that he carries and we'll talk
more about that later but like these
other two showing up if there was ever a
fight to be had here it's long since
gone they overpower these guys with a
quickness right these inheritors they
overpower these spiderman so fast and
like superior spiderman's like we have
to go we can't stay here if we stay here
we're all gonna die i'm sounding a
retreat and some of them don't want to
but it's like no like like you guys
remember that scene from aliens when
when uh when hicks was like marines we
are leaving it's that right i mean it's
just it's a massacre it's them just like
trying to live and so ultimately they
actually the inheritors end up fighting
amongst themselves and that's just what
superior spider-man and those guys need
is to to basically have a distraction to
make their escape they open their
portals and they bail they immediately
take off and so following that you have
this kind of discussion that goes on
where one superior spider-man ends up
creating an arm for one of the
spider-man to basically upgrade his
cybernetic devices so he can you know
hack into the systems from alkamax
without being detected and he's like
your job is to hunt for the names of the
inheritors throughout the entire history
that alkamax has at their disposal if
they're moving through universes it also
means they're moving through time so
they could appear at any point in time
across the entirety of the multiverse if
they're hunting spider-man there's a
good chance they've appeared in the past
find their names and that assignment
actually ends up going out to the six
armed spider-man as well right to kind
of hunt throughout the entirety of the
time stream space and time itself and
find some reference for these guys
anywhere the next thing is it actually
ends up going to spider-man india and
well he really calls him turtleneck but
it's basically spider-man noir where
he's like you're going to find out where
their home universe is if they are
hunting spider-man throughout the
multiverse then it means they're
retreating somewhere they're going
somewhere they live somewhere find their
home whether it's an entire universe or
some pocket dimension somewhere find out
where they live and so what he actually
ends up doing is pulling aside ashley
barton and pulling aside assassin's
spiderman and this is one of the cool
things because these were the two who
immediately said we have to kill this
inheritor guy and so one of the things
superior spider-man picked up on is that
the other spider-man who were here are
all very closely modeled after peter
parker right they're just alternate
reality versions of peter in the sense
that they almost exactly mirror his
mannerisms but also his moral compass
they're not willing to kill and so it's
one of the things that kind of goes on
because he says i wanted to speak to the
two of you privately i feel we share a
certain perspective that eludes our
allies and that's when assassin's
spider-man's like don't dance around it
we're killers and superior spider-man
says yes he's like i wasn't really
dancing around it it's more than that
the others may have killed in dire
circumstances i don't really know but
it's clear to me that we three have seen
things that they have not brutality
devastation darkness the others think
they've seen the worst that life has to
offer because they've lost a loved one
or two but we have seen the face of true
evil and we understand what is required
to stop it this is incredibly important
because he goes on to say these beings
we fight belong to the same family to
end their threat we may have to commit a
genocide and by way of that we may find
our allies standing in our way i.e if it
comes down to it i need to know you're
willing to kill other spider-man in
order to ensure we can end this threat
it's pretty extreme right it's just that
severe of a conflict in the eyes of
superior spider-man but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end let me know what you guys think down
in the comments section for those of you
guys who never saw or never read uh
spider-verse it's a really really cool
story and it only gets better when you
end up with like cosmic spider-man right
so like spider-man with the enigma force
that guy was nuts but let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section we're gonna bring this video to
an end and i will catch you all later
peace